هكذا استقبل الحبر الاعظم في القصر الملكي
من قبل ملك البحرين حمد بن عيسى ال خليفه
وكبار المسؤولين والدبلوماسيين في اطار
زياره هي الاولى من نوعها للبابا فرنسيس
الى البحرين هدفها التاكيد على اهميه
الحوار بين الاديان وتحسين العلاقات مع
العالم الاسلامي واكد عاهل البحرين على
اهميه السلام بين الدول
الى احد مبادرات بلادنا دعما
لجهود السلام العالميه والمتمثله في اعلان
مملكه البحرين
الذي دعمنا صدوره قبل عده سنوات
كوثيقه تدعو
لرفض التمييز الديني
وتدين الانف والتحريض
ينضم هذا الاعلان الى غيره من الوثائق
الهامه التي تسعى لذات الهدف
عقوبه
الانسان والحريه الدينيه
وحقوق الانسان الاساسيه يجب ان يتم
تعزيزها الحق في الحياه في المقام الاول
بما في ذلك اولئك الذين يعاقبون والذين لا
ينبغي ازهق اروهم
اعضاء المسلمين في جامع
الامام احمد الطيب قبل ان يتراس الحبر
الاعظم قداس يوم السبت في ملعب البحرين
الوطني
الخليج بعد زياره تاريخيه الى الامارات
عام 2019